If it's a cold that blows through, do you
know where you're going?
Savor your fate as you taste the continuation of a nameless encounter.
[Music] I
put my ear to my chest and hear the
sound of something impossible. Feelings that
don't go back anywhere. They're
sweet and bitter, but their true identity is you.  I tried to read deeply into things that shouldn't have happened.I
found that smile that I'm sure no one has seen until today.You, the
bad guy who changes, were shining with
light.The
seasons keep coming and going,
and if we don't change forever, it's time for your
eyes to sway, sway, and
begin.  Then again, why the world?
By being next to each other, our hearts want to overlap someday.